yesterday I told you that
president-elect Donald who clearly loves
the flag as we can see from this picture
uh said that if you burn the flag you
should get a year in prison or be
stripped of citizenship as a reminder
Donald Trump sending this out around
seven am one of many tweets that went
out nobody should be allowed to burn the
American flag if they do there must be
consequences perhaps loss of citizenship
or a year in jail now the key points
from yesterday to refresh your memory
number one you're not allowed to take
citizenship away as punishment a 1958
Supreme Court decision rejected the
practice of stripping citizenship as a
form of criminal punishment number two
it just so happens that flag burning is
constitutionally protected uh and many
other Republicans realize this so I will
play for you or show you rather and read
to you some of the many quotes from
Republicans that are not standing by
this ridiculous and grotesque idea from
Donald Trump starting with Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell who said
the Supreme Court has held that that
activity is a protected First Amendment
right a form of unpleasant speech and in
this country we have a long tradition of
respecting unpleasant speech I happen to
support the Supreme Court's decision on
that matter in Mitch McConnell actually
wrote an op-ed about ten years ago
saying that if you burn the flag you're
a quote degenerate attention seeker but
that doesn't mean that we make burning
the flag illegal we don't have to like
the speech to recognize it cannot be
curtailed then we have Michigan
Republican congressman Justin a mash who
also went on Twitter and defended the
undeniable constitutionality of flag
burning he tweeted nobody should burn
the American flag but our Constitution
secures us our rights secures our right
to do so no president is allowed to burn
the First Amendment and Wisconsin
Republican congressman Sean Duffy told
CNN he also disagrees with Donald Trump
on this saying I think the court is
probably right that we want to protect
those people who want to protest and
their right to actually demonstrate with
disgracing our flag
even though so many of us who love our
country and love our flag object to it
and lastly we have House Majority Leader
Kevin McCarthy a Republican from
California who put it more simply on
yesterday's Morning Joe on MSNBC we have
a First Amendment right we'll protect
our First Amendment that's what the
court has upheld question one how on
earth did Trump end up thinking it was a
good idea to tweet about punishing
people for burning the flag at 7am you
have a sense of that part right Pat
there was something Fox talked about it
at some point yeah when the story broke
everyone was super confused but it turns
out that 6-30 a.m. yesterday morning Fox
News did a story about Hampshire College
one of the students burning a flag there
okay and half an hour later that's when
he sent out this tweet so it seemed like
it was completely out of the blue it
turns out the president-elect was just
watching Fox News at six thirty in the
morning which it which according to Tony
Schwartz the guy who wrote the art of
the deal for Donald Trump a shocking
breaking news Trump didn't actually
write that book which he says is
basically as good as the Bible or right
up there is one of his two favorite
books uh we're gonna talk with Rachel
about the Hampshire College story on the
bonus show the the issue I'm having here
rachel is that supporting the First
Amendment for things you like but
supporting jail for things you don't
like said this is if if we're ever going
to define what we mean by strongman
populist authoritarianism which is
exactly what Donald Trump is it's this
right making a big show of how important
the Constitution and the First Amendment
are except when it comes two types of
speech you don't like and if anybody had
any confusion or doubt as to whether
Trump is one of those authoritarians
this basically eliminates all doubt
doesn't it it does eliminate all that
but most of your points were focused on
talking about the Republicans who were
denouncing what he was saying but this
is we've seen Republicans say before one
citizen should be stripped of their
citizenship for doing things there was
Ted Cruz who said that people should be
stripped of citizenship if they
pronounce any allegiances to foreign
terrorist groups and Rand Paul echoed
that and then there was Newt Gingrich
who said any Muslims who believe in
Sharia law should be revoked citizenship
so they're kind of viewing it as a
privilege as opposed to a right
so it that they're all denouncing it but
then it's kind of a it's another example
of picking when certain punishment
supply right upper critical it's very
critical and at your you're right and
people have been emailing me also saying
but David at one point Hillary Clinton
sort of supported an amendment to ban
flag burning with like a
five-hundred-dollar fine which by the
way is very different than stripping
citizenship I would reject that also and
be against it she ultimately went back
on that Hillary Clinton's not involved
in this anymore right i don't know why
the focus is will trump wants to strip
citizenship for burning the flag hillary
clinton once wanted to find people $500
yeah i'm also against that but number
one the scope is totally different but
more importantly ideologically what is
Hillary Clinton have to do with this at
this point and you raise this point
yesterday but if you're solely an
American citizen and you get your
citizenship test ripping away yeah what
happens to you you have no place to go
yeah where do you go if you're if you've
only if you were born in the US and only
have American citizenship and now you're
no longer Susan I don't understand the
logistics of where it is that you go uh
and at you know what I don't know that
we're going to get an answer to that
from Donald Trump although what I do
understand is all the people emailing me
saying David I'm rereading George
Orwell's 1984 uh and sales of that book
a record numbers on amazon.com and I
think we understand why Warby Parker is
offering a free five day home try-on to
give you the opportunity to check out
their glasses I personally where Warby
Parker glasses when I'm not wearing my
contact lenses and I also started with
one of these free at home try ons of
five pairs of glasses you can get your
free home try-on and support the david
pakman show at Warby Parker trial
dot-com / tdps I don't really like going
into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home try-on I was able to pick
five pairs that i liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I like the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high
$300 for prescription glasses hi which
is just insane Warby Parker glasses
start at $95 that's what mine cost and
for every pair of glasses sold Warby
Parker distributes a pair of glasses to
someone in need you can try five pairs
and see what you like check out the
at-home trial and support our show by
going to Warby Parker dot-com / TDPS it
costs nothing